a Jonas baby is coming ready for it
according to multiple reports sophie
Turner and Joe Jonas are expecting their
first child together
the couple has been married almost a
year they tied the knot last May I feel
like a new woman they pulled off the
surprise wedding of the year in Viva Las
Vegas
Reverend Elvis included with this ring
they were definitely entertainers there
were a lot of fun and we have to take a
moment to thank Diplo again who recorded
the whole dang thing
a month later jofi had a more formal
ceremony in France since then the two
have looked more in love than ever the
last time we saw Sophie and Joe was at
the Grammys in February the mom-to-be
stunt in a fun Louie Vuitton dress while
Joe was all smiles it's a good accessory
but while we're patiently waiting for
baby Jonas to arrive we know that Joe
will be one supportive dad to be it
means so much to have him here it's just
like the best support the best person to
calm me down and keep me calm and if I
end up crying I have a shoulder to cry
on and of course the new bundle of joy
will live the good life with the Jay
sisters it's a whole family situation I
never thought that it would be like that
so we've created our own hashtag of
wives on tour but it's so fun because
everyone is with their kids and their
wives but it's just such a beautiful
vibe
[Music]